- Khan Academy students, what's goin' on?
It's Akbar Gbaja-Biamila, host
of American Ninja Warrior.
I just wanted to check in with you guys,
but also to wish you a happy New Year.
It's 2021.
Things are gonna be a lot different.
And I know in 2020
things got crazy, right?
We had the isolation and a
lot of us were struggling,
going through the ups and the downs
and things at home were
starting the change
because of COVID-19.
Well, this is a new year, a new mindset.
And, as you can see,
I'm inside of my office
and you can see some
of my football jerseys.
And what I love about football,
what I love about American Ninja Warrior,
is that you constantly have obstacles
that you have to overcome.
That is going to happen
regardless of it's a good year
or a bad year that we saw,
and I put it in quote
because that's all relative,
that we saw in 2020.
So my coach used to tell me this,
and I truly do believe this,
is that tough times don't
last, but tough people do.
And to be tough, what does that mean?
Does that mean you have to growl, like
(Akbar growls)
No, what it means is that
you're willing to accept
the challenges that are in front of you.
You're willing to go with
the ups and the downs,
but you're also knowing that
you have this trajectory,
you're going up.
So to the Khan Academy
students, I say this to you:
be an American Ninja
Warrior in the classroom,
at home, doing your personal life.
Whatever it is that you're
going, have that mindset
that I will overcome.
You're overcome whatever those obstacles.
And then when I see you at that buzzer,
when you get up that warp wall in life,
in school, in your personal life,
and you hit that buzzer, I'm gonna say,
I see you, I see you hitting that buzzer!
So, take on 2021 with a new
mindset, a new attitude.
Don't look in the past.
It's just something for you
to reflect and move forward.
I'll leave you with this:
take every stumbling block
in school, in life, whatever,
and turn it into a stepping stone.
You got that?
Stumbling block into a stepping stone,
that's your challenge for 2021, all right?
You guys are Khan Academy ninja warriors!
Have a great school year
and we'll talk soon.